- [Announcer] This video
is brought to you by Keeps
(relaxed electronic music)
- What's up, guys. Michael here.
Living through the
pandemic has been terrible
for obvious reasons,
but especially early on
it was also a time of
weird experimentation
with fads like cocktails in
coffee cups, Jackbox marathons,
and codependent relationships
with sourdough starters.
And of course, it also
kickstarted a new conversation
about working from home.
Prior to the modern plague,
only 6% of people worked remotely.
That's ballooned to a whopping
42% of U.S. workers today,
including basically all of
your friends here at Wisecrack.
But with everything opening back up
and execs calling for
a return to the office,
is that about to change?
Will we have to leave our bed desks
and business sweats behind?
And do we lose something when
we stop working in person?
Let's find out in this Wisecrack edition:
Is Working from Home Here to Stay?
Before we get into it, I
wanna give a quick shout out
to this week's sponsor: Keeps.
By now, you may have heard the statistic
that two out of three guys
experience male pattern
baldness of some kind,
by the time they hit
35, which is alarming.
But luckily, Keeps is here to help.
It's a subscription service
that makes it easier
and more affordable to prevent hair loss.
First, you'll schedule a free consultation
with a licensed Keeps doctor.
They can help you get
the right combination
of FDA-approved prescriptions
and over-the-counter medications
to help prevent further hair loss.
You can message your Keeps doctor 24/7
to update them on your
progress or ask them questions.
Your automatic refills
are shipped to your door
every three months, so
you don't have to worry
about running out of medication,
and you can skip trips to the pharmacy.
Keeps has more five-star reviews
than any of its competitors.
Get started today,
and you can see results
in four to six months.
If you're ready to take
action and prevent hair loss
go to keeps.com/wisecrack
or click the link in the description
to receive 50% off your first order.
That's K-E-E-P-S.com/wisecrack.
Now, back to the show.
There's a lot of debate
about whether working
from home is good or bad.
In general, most employees
prefer to work from home,
but there are downsides.
One study found that 70%
of remote professionals
work weekends, and 45% work more
than they did before the pandemic.
All the time we saved on the commute
got funneled straight back into work.
This has led to an even blurrier
line between work and life,
because both now occupy the same space.
A lot of workers are now
expected to be accessible 24/7.
That, in addition to
missing your work friends
and your water cooler gossip,
has resulted in a lot of burned out,
depressed and dissociated people
trying not to lose their minds
in their living room offices.
But working from home isn't all bad.
For one, it saves everyone money.
Employees don't have to pay for gas
or lunch from Panda Express,
and employers don't have to
worry about office spaces
and stocking up on industrial
rolls of toilet paper.
Although, your boss should be paying
to outfit your home office,
but that's a story for another day.
Employees are also more productive
than they were pre-pandemic,
because they're under
less pressure to look busy
and aren't constantly being interrupted
by guys who won't stop
talking about body hacking.
For most workers, this is reason enough
to keep working at home.
But odds are your boss disagrees.
While most employees aren't in a hurry
to rush back to a soulless
husk of an office building,
execs and higher level management
are pushing to get them
back in their cubicles.
The central argument is that remote work
lacks a certain je ne sais qua.
J.P. Morgan CEO Jamie
Dimon summed it up as such:
"It doesn't work for
those who want to hustle.
It doesn't work for
spontaneous idea generation.
It doesn't work for culture."
Which made us wonder,
is the in-person office
really all it's cracked up to be?
Do they actually promote
hustle, creativity, and culture?
What are employers seeing that we aren't?
Dimon's quote reflects
a broader preoccupation
among the higher-ups, namely hustle.
This isn't anything new.
Executives have been concerned
about their employees
performing with gusto since forever.
To understand why, meet
Frederick Winslow Taylor,
an early 20th century mechanical engineer
at Bethlehem Steel.
You see, season one of
the Industrial Revolution
wasn't the best as far as attendance
and productivity were concerned.
Early factories were designed
after workhouses and prisons,
so, understandably, no
one wanted to be there.
Plus, workers used to the flexibilities
afforded by working on farms
or in small family businesses
had never had to clock in for
their boss at 9:00 before.
Now, all of a sudden,
they had to skip Christmas
to shovel coal into a furnace all day.
- It's Christmas Day.
You gave me the day off.
- Would I do a thing like that?
- Taylor observed this and concluded
that workers were inherently lazy.
His solution? Optimization.
So, like a little industrial gremlin,
he crawled around the factory
and timed workers with a stopwatch,
looking for any wasted movements
to shave off their routines.
Taylor's goal was to make workers
as machine-like as possible.
They went from performing
complex processes on their own
to only being responsible
for a single step.
It was more soul-sucking than
making out with a Dementor.
Industrialist Henry Ford
eventually used Taylor's ideas
to maximize productivity
via the infamous Ford assembly line.
Taylor found that the
more data he collected
and the more control he
had over the process,
the better workers performed.
But to make this function smoothly,
he needed a steady supply of loyal workers
committed to the business hierarchy,
so he created the middle manager.
Originally, they took the
form of disciplinarians
and/or gang bosses.
As middle managers spread
across the workplace,
they kept watch, fined or expelled workers
for nefarious offenses,
such as talking and eating,
and made sure all the
mind-numbing activities
were done on time, or else.
Around the 1930s, people
started coming around
to the then novel idea that
workers performed better
when they weren't afraid of
being punched in the head.
Middle managers' job descriptions expanded
from maintaining productivity at all costs
to also asking concerned questions like,
"You hangin' in there?"
This shift created the modern manager.
But despite their growing
concern for employee welfare,
they're not all warm handshakes
and pats on the back.
And thanks to Taylor,
there's still a narrative
that workers are innately lazy
and managers continue to
fixate on surveillance
as a way of controlling productivity.
At the start of the pandemic,
use of surveillance
software increased by 50%
and continues to rise
in spite of productivity
being at an all-time high.
The software doesn't
just give your employer
the ability to look through your email
and the memes you post on Slack.
- They can control your webcam and mic,
take screenshots of your desktop,
and monitor your activity
down to the keystroke.
So, you know, like Big Brother
(beep) but absolutely real.
And this is a natural evolution
for an American management system
built on not trusting
people to do their jobs.
And how do you monitor
a big group of people
who you think are lazy babies?
You schedule a whole lot of meetings.
Indeed, meetings have increased
in length and frequency
over the past 50 years,
to the extent that executives on average
spend over half their work week in them.
This wouldn't be an issue if
meetings were actually helpful,
but more often than not employees report
they're unproductive,
inefficient and disruptive.
During the pandemic, managers
scheduled even more meetings.
It sure seems like what the
anti-work-from-home crew
is missing isn't work but
the optics of doing work.
Okay, so maybe offices and
the people who run them
are built on some serious trust issues.
But what about the
spontaneous idea generation
that's rumored to happen at the office?
Do we need to be in person
to harness that sweet, sweet synergy?
Not if you ask the people
designing our offices.
Currently 70-80% of American
offices are open plan.
While many attribute
this innovative design
to Silicon Valley tech companies,
they're the dirty work of, you guessed it,
our good friend Frederick Taylor.
He arranged workers in
endless rows of desks
with offices lining the outside
for managers to keep watch.
The open office plan was
hailed as a huge success,
because it improved
productivity, efficiency,
and made surveilling your
workforce even easier.
On the downside, it
encouraged noise, distractions
and tons of animosity towards the guy
chewing a tuna fish sandwich
with his mouth open.
Believe it or not, cubicles
were originally designed
as a solution to the chaotic
grind of the open office.
But through a series of cost cuts,
offices quickly devolved
into cubicle farms.
So companies swerved back
to the open office plan,
which is conveniently cheaper,
because they don't have to buy any walls,
and supposedly more conducive
to happy collaboration.
But it turns out that open
floor plans have been found
to almost universally
increase stress levels,
heighten blood pressure,
as well as cause burnout.
Also, open offices are downright terrible
for spontaneous
communication and creativity.
Surveys find that open offices
actually resulted in 70% less
face-to-face communication,
and use of electronic
messaging increased by 22-50%.
Most people just plug in their
headphones, blast some BTS,
and do their best to
tune everyone else out.
And tuning people out is hard
when nobody has any privacy
and where Steve in the sales department
has a super loud phone voice.
All these interruptions mean less time
for the distraction-free concentration
that actually leads to good ideas.
The more companies try
to control creativity,
the more they actually snuff it out.
So why are executives pushing for this?
Because they generally don't
work in an open office.
They have their own private offices
with walls and doors
and space and privacy.
The office that they want to return to
is significantly less (beep)
than the office their
employees will return to.
You'd want to go back to the office, too,
if you had a private beverage fridge
and assistants to grab your lunch.
But we also have to admit
that, at least for some of us,
working from home can
be incredibly isolating.
It's easy to feel disconnected
from your coworkers and your company
when you only interact
with them through a screen,
especially when you find out
they were much taller than you thought.
Maybe going into work is worth it
to preserve company culture,
but what even is company culture?
The idea of corporate culture was predated
by a period of economic
stagnation in the '70s
that gave rise to a historic
amount of downsizing
in the '80s and '90s.
This resulted in a huge
wave of corporate cynicism,
as employees realized that companies
no longer had their
best interests at heart.
Organization consultants
Terence Deal and Allan Kennedy
tried to repair this rift between
corporations and employees
with their book "The
New Corporate Cultures".
They promised that a business
could cut costs, stay lean,
and make their employees less miserable
with company culture.
Business schools ate this up
like it was thousand-dollar caviar.
More democratic practices were introduced,
like treating employees
like responsible adults,
in addition to team building
events, more cake and parties.
The company was a family again;
that is, if your family is ruthless enough
to (beep) can you while everyone
else is doing goat yoga.
And as much as they claim
they aren't like other mega-corporations,
venture capitalists
promoted the exact same
toxic company culture, just
with different frosting.
Startups used the idea that
an app could change the world
to encourage obsessive
devotion to the company
and to justify the destruction
of any semblance of work-life balance.
- This isn't just my job.
This is my religion.
- Even if you don't work at one of these
IPA-spewing mega corporations,
company culture still sucks.
An organization's goal
will always be profit
and optimization first,
employee health and stability
second, or third, or fourth.
What's more, the company culture movement
hasn't exactly made
traditional office spaces
better at being inclusive.
After all, traditional offices
were specifically designed
with the comfort of usually
white male executives in mind,
right down to the standardized
68 to 76 degree temperatures,
because sweaty suits.
At the end of the workday,
company culture is just an
enticing emotional narrative
that makes workers invest more time
and energy into the company.
It's no surprise that the main
defendants of company culture
are largely the same executives
pushing to go back to the office,
because the office has
always worked best for them.
But much to your boss's dismay,
offices probably aren't going back
to the way they used to be,
or at least not across the board.
We might just be on the brink
of an exciting turning point.
Ongoing remote work is
changing everything,
even the very shape of our cities.
Mark Muro, a Senior
Fellow and Policy Director
at the Brookings institution,
noted that remote workers
are moving out of major
metropolitan areas,
like New York or the Bay
Area, to the suburbs,
creating a donut-shaped population density
around major cities.
Workers wanna be close enough
to commute to the office
a couple days a week
but still gain the financial
benefits of suburban life.
The influx of remote workers
to suburbs and small cities
is both good and bad.
On the one hand, remote workers
support the local economy
by working out of coffee shops, cafes,
and other mixed-use spaces.
On the other hand, the influx
of people making city money
snapping up houses in smaller markets
are causing housing prices to
rise at unprecedented rates.
Workers supported by the local economy
are being priced outta town.
Plus, many small cities and suburbs
simply were not built to
hold this many people.
They don't have the infrastructure,
like transportation and available housing,
to support the sudden
increase in population.
This is contributing to
a growing class divide,
which remote urban workers were
originally trying to escape.
Speaking of big metropolitan areas,
are they just a lost cause?
Culture journalists Charlie Warzel
and Anne Helen Petersen don't think so.
They argue that, because
work in the office
is no longer an incentive to live in town,
city officials should
work with urban planners
to step up their game.
Large office buildings can be transformed
into multi-use spaces.
Cities may shift from giving tax subsidies
for new factories and warehouses
to investing in schools,
parks, and the arts
to encourage residents to stick around.
It could also mean
investing in street dining,
better transit, improved walkability,
and more flexible workspaces
for people who don't want to
work at home or the office.
In essence, cities may move
from appeasing job makers
to greasing the palms of the
people actually doing the work.
But no matter where we are,
we still have a long way to go
in negotiating our boundaries with work.
As we become more spatially
decentralized from the office,
maybe it's time to make work
more decentralized from our lives.
But what do you guys think?
What if work wasn't the
center of our lives and homes?
Could working remotely be the key
to escaping our corporate overlords
and real pants once and for all?
Let us know what you
think in the comments.
Big thanks to all our patrons,
and be sure to check out
our new Patreon features.
Hit that subscribe button
like you're punching sign
out on your time card,
and don't forget to ring that bell.
And as always, thanks for watching.
Later.
(upbeat electronic music)